ah yes so I had to put boundaries on
people that's what my therapist told me
that I had to put boundaries on people
that was like my assignment
and one guy that was like eating in the
[ __ ] dining hall would uh
[ __ ]
pull his chair out too loud
and I'm like Larry David sitting there
I'm just like how does this bother me
that my dude I'm like a non-vet dude
I'm like a [ __ ] Nom vet when it comes
to noises dude I used to go out with
this woman when I was 32 and she hated
loud noises and it always bothered me
I'm like it's just a noise and dude
[ __ ] if I don't have that now is
it a condition loud noises look that up
loud noises you can't be around loud
noises I don't know whatever the [ __ ]
it's called audio sensitory whatever the
hell dude
he would
roam the [ __ ] chair would come out it
would be like all of a sudden an
elephant just
Rome and I ah
and the guy's a [ __ ] Navy SEAL or
whatever the [ __ ] he actually and so he
gets up and does everything all loud
nice guy handsome and [ __ ] and [ __ ]
and I'm oh
hey bro haha right and he'd be like and
then he would go
like a fun guy and I'm like yeah dude I
get that's the thing to do as men but
holy [ __ ] man I got a seven-year-old
inside my chest and we don't like that
but I swallow it you know because I'm me
and I don't want him not to like me and
I'll sit I'll sit with it okay I'll sit
with it
and uh
so then uh
I gotta set these boundaries you know
like two weeks in and like you gotta sit
pounds you gotta give somebody a
boundary a day and I'm like for [ __ ]
sake all right I'm gonna give this
[ __ ] a boundary a boundary
so I'm sitting there at the [ __ ]
dining hall it's just me and he's at
another table I like the guy he's a
friend of mine gets up bro I go
and I I stand up and I say hey
hey uh but he says sup and I'm like
um
could you not
uh
could you not do that so loud with the
chair when you
when you get up it's uh it's it's so
loud
and he said
huh
and I said
I gotta
I gotta put boundaries on on people
that they said I have to practice
putting boundaries
on people
and he said
that's not a boundary
and I wasn't really equipped for that
part so I said what do you mean and he
said well a boundary is like
hey
um
when you do this
it makes me feel this way
and if you keep doing it then I'm gonna
have to
do something else and remove myself from
the situation I was like oh okay right
I'm saying it wrong
um Okay so
when you
um
moved the chair like that like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] I didn't say that but I wanted
to but it was right I was doing it the
therapeutic system like when you get up
and do that you uh
it it's loud for me and if if you do do
that when I'm studying here and I'm I'm
reading
books telling telling me how [ __ ] up I
am and filling out the worksheets on
how much of a piece of [ __ ] I am right
and I want to write letters fictitious
letters when I'm writing fictitious
letters to my
mom and dad and
that I'm never gonna send them because
it's just an exercise right as I'm
writing a letter with my left hand
two
minor child on what what I might need
from him as a 42 year old man I'm I'm I
can't hear that I'm gonna have to go
into the other room
um and uh
and so so that's that and he said huh
okay
um well I don't want you to have to
leave the room so uh I will
I'll be more conscious of it man and um
I won't I won't do it so loud
and I said oh
thanks
and in a beat passed and I said
I said out loud
I feel so awful right now
and he said really and I said
yeah man I feel [ __ ] horrible saying
that [ __ ] and he said why and I said I
mean he's 40 I'm 42 and we're standing
there and we just ate
kiss poor halibut
and cereal for dessert because there's
no sugar Cheerios by the way and and he
says uh and I and he says why
and I said
because I'm afraid when I say that
you'll like me less
42.
it's 40.
he's killed people
in the ocean
he's an elite Navy SEAL
I'm a dumbest [ __ ] comedian
I talk about things like
pants on stage
and here we are looking at each other
no let me paint the picture and I don't
mean to do this in any shitty way or
braggadocious but we're both equally as
handsome dude
that's neither here nor there but I just
want you to know that
and I said I want you to like me and he
says oh well I do like you
and that was that
and me and the seven-year-old inside my
chest
finished our work and you know what
when I when I when when when we were
joking about the [ __ ] chair
beforehand like a week before and I was
like bro okay that's so [ __ ] loud
what the [ __ ] and he would go
you know
um he goes like this he said he uh ice i
i he said do I really do that loud and I
was like yeah man it's it's loud as [ __ ]
you know and he was like yeah oh and he
was like do you know like who's bad at
it now there's three dudes that are real
bad at it here and he's like really and
I was like yeah he's like how do you
even know and I was like that's the mind
I got bro this is how it is for me
and he says uh oh well who's the worst
and it was him
so I said you man dude he laughed that
was a great that was great there were
such moments of levity there it was
hilarious crazy crazy crazy
crazy crazy
crazy congratulations